ما يزيد عن 12 ساعه للعمليه العسكريه ولا
تزال حتى هذه اللحظه متواصله هنا في مدينه
طول كرم نحن الان نتواجد امام مخيم طول
كرم وسط اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه تدور حتى
هذه اللحظه على وقع العمليه العسكريه التي
لا تزال متواصله نرصد هنا اليات الاحتلال
العسكريه التي تخرج للتو من محيط مخيم طول
كرم وسط اشتباكات مسلحه لا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه متواصله دمار واسع خلفه الاحتلال
في البنى التحتيه من شبكات الصرف الصحي
وشبكات المياه وايضا شبكات الكهرباء حاله
من الدمار التي تسود المنطقه نرصد هنا
ايضا جرافه من طراز دي 9 والتي يستخدمها
الاحتلال خلال
اقتحاماتهم لمدن الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وقراها منذ السابع من اكتوبر نشاهد هنا
عدد من الاليات العسكريه التي بدات للتو
بالتحرك في محيط مخيم طول كرم في هذه
اللحظات بعد تدمير لعدد من الطرقات والبنى
التحتيه داخل هذا المخيم هنا الصوره تبدو
واضحه لتحرك واستمرار تحرك الاليات
العسكريه في هذه اللحظات هنا في هذه
المنطقه كما تشاهدون في هذه الصوره 12
ساعه على العمليه العسكريه خلف الاحتلال
دمار واسع في البنى التحتيه من مدينه طول
كرم ليث جعار
الجزيره